in the turkish region of cappadocia
hidden in the hallowed rocks lies some
of the oldest christian churches in the
world
[Music]
the gorham open air museum is a cluster
of monasteries and churches dating all
the way back to the 4th century
2.6 million years ago a volcanic
eruption of the nearby mount or shais
resulted in the formation of
mushroom-shaped fairy chimneys
[Music]
each church that makes up the gorham
open air museum is housed within a
separate soft rock cave
more than 10 churches make up the museum
inside each church are wall paintings
known as frescoes examples of old
classics from the byzantine art period
these incredible paintings have managed
to retain their clarity and colors
throughout the years thanks to frequent
restorations
in 1984 the gorham open air museum
became one of the first two sites in
turkey to be designated a unesco world
heritage site
but it's the museum's extensive history
and unique structures that have made it
one of cappadocia's most visited
attractions
you